مظاهرات في مختلف عواصم ومدن العالم
الكبرى تخرج تنديدا بالعدوان الاسرائيلي
على قطاع غزه حيث استشهد نحو
2800 من الرجال والنساء والاطفال من جراء
القصف الاسرائيلي العشوائي على سكان
القطاع لبيك لبيك يا لقد كان الشارع دائما
تعبيرا عن ضمير الانسانيه في انكاره
لفضاءات القوه عندما تتحلل من كل قيد
اخلاقي او قانوني يزع ذهابها بعيدا في
الهمجيه ان تحيل بنايه سكنيه الى مقبره
للامن القاطنين فيها ذلك شر محض بتعبير
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الذي راعه ما
اصاب الاسرائيليين صبيحه السبت السابع من
اكتوبر لكنه كغيره من الزعماء الغربيين لم
يرى ولم يروا الفضاح التي رافقت قصف
اسرائيل
لغزه على مدار اليوم مخلفا الالاف بين
قتيل
وجريح سيعبر طرف من الشارع الامريكي عن
رفضه واستنكاره للجريمه الكبرى التي
ترتكبها اسرائيل في غزه في تحد صارخ لكل
مواريث التجربه الانسانيه في رفض الظلم
فالحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه كشفت عمق
الهوه بين مثاليه الاقوال في مديح الكرامه
الانسانيه بين السقوط في الافعال في
العاصمه باريس تلقي الحكومه بوشاح حزنها
على برج ايفل تضامنا مع اسرائيل بعد
الهجوم عليها لكن الحكومه الفرنسيه
المتعاطفه مع اسرائيل تقرر منع اي مضاهرات
مؤيده للفلسطينيين في غزه او متضامنه
معهم بيد ان المظاهرات تخرج يسير فيها
العاديون من الناس الذين يجدون في انف
القدره على استبشار الجريمه في بريطانيا
التي اتخذت كذلك موقفا متشددا ضد اي مظاهر
يتم فيها التعبير عن التضامن مع
الفلسطينيين كان خروج اي مظاهره تندد
بالعدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه يعتبر خروجا
على موقف الحكومه المنحاز انحيازا كاملا
الى اسرائيل فرئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك يريد ادخال الجميع سرادق العزاء
الاسرائيلي لكن الم تستدل بوصله ضميرها
المفرقه بين الضحيه وبين القاتل فالدنيا
تعلم ان اسرائيل هي خطيئه بريطانيا الكبرى
فمن رحمها خرجت
ومباركتها كانت قد نشات دوله تشرعن وجودها
في النشاه والاستمرار بقتل الفلسطيني
وتشريده تخرج المظاهرات من المانيا مندده
بالمجازر الاسرائيليه في غزه والمانيا
سيره اخرى في متن الهولوكوست
الذي الزم الضمير الغربي ثقلا كلما قام
منه سقط به المانيا لا ترى ما يحل
بالفلسطينيين من تقتيل وتشريد لكن
المظاهرات فيها تراها رغم تاكيدات
المستشار الالماني اولاف شولز على وقوف
بلاده الحازم والراسخ مع اسرائيل لا تعدم
الشوارع في سدني وفي غيرها من المدن
الاستراليه احرارا يقولون لا للعدوان
الاسرائيلي في
غزه ولهؤلاء نظائرهم في كندا التي شهدت هي
الاخرى مظاهرات مؤيده للفلسطينيين
شاجبة الاسرائ واقامه دولته المستقله وليس
كجنوب افريقيا من خبر معنى الفصل العنصري
ومعنى التحرر بعدض طول
الاستعباد
الله اكبر في اقطار العالم الاسلامي تكتسي
المظاهرات مى اضافيا فهي تاييد وتضامن
وتعاطف وهي بجانب ذلك كله فيها شيء
كالاعصار الا من جاكارتا في اقصى الشرق
مرورا بباكستان
فالجزائر بتجربتها النضال ضد الاستعمار
الفرنسي في اليمن كانت تخرج المظاهرات
بعشرات الالاف وفي المغرب وفي تونس تح نا
في فلسطين وفي
الكويت لعب العربي الاص وفي
العراق وغيرها منب العربيه والاسلاميه
وحده شعوريه تمتد في جغرافيه واسعه لا
تؤكد فقط ان القضيه الفلسطينيه لا تعدم
انصارا ومؤيدين لها في بقاع الارض ولكنها
تكشف كذلك ان توحش القوه كان دائما نقيضا
لما هو انساني لما هو حق الاعتداء
الاسرائيلي العشوائي في غزه مثال صارخ على
ذلك لمن يريد ان يرى
l